alors vanessa paradis vous êtes devenue
une mère très très attentif vous êtes
ordonné maintenant avant que vous ne
vous fait les valises quand vous partez
en quand vous partez en vacances étaient
sérieuses
donc quand on fait une interview très
sérieuses et c'est l'interview expliqué
à ma fille
en la bouche pendant le dégagement raté
votre fille vous demande maintenant
pourquoi on meurt encore mère ce qu'elle
dans histoire et un début un milieu et
une fin et puis il faut bien que ça
s'arrête semble au bout d'un moment on
devient complètement à massy à la
cuillère mais après il ya autre chose
sur twitter vous le dirai ça sert à quoi
de travailler puisqu'il suffit d'aller à
la machine pour prendre de l'argent
baa à occuper ses journées et a mangé
mon père est dit c'est le taxi de la
liberté d'argent j'aime bien cet ex
principaux ce taxi csat
récurrents la première
maman c'est quoi ce que vous mettez dans
vos cigarettes avec papa
amélie et non j'aime explique pour
l'instant ça sans moi c'est du tabac
donc ça va ya pas de problème pas de
problème non mais de toute façon j'ai
lui expliquerai je préfère
faire visiter puisse passer les
frontières tranquille
8 kg aussi
aux états unis et moi
pourquoi papa il a fait un baiser sur la
bouche à la baby sitter bagis tirait
mais parce que parce qu'ils l'aiment
bien qui voulait lui dire bonjour puis
après
50 balles de leurs on peut quand même
par un bisou quoi maman pourquoi on
t'entend mois la radio en ce moment
parce que parce que les gens les aiment
pas trop méchants sont en ce moment et
dit maman qu'est la question qui n'a pas
de réponse
c'est chiant les gosses
c'est pourquoi pourquoi je t'aime pas de
réponse c'est comme ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux